entre beigbeder nicholas ray vous
préférez qui souvent l'associent nicolas
rey et beigbeder et c'est étrange parce
que je trouve que c'est pas du tout la
même littérature en format on va faire
une interview nicolas rey contre
beigbeder et c'est vous qui répondait
louis celui qui couche avec les plus
jolies filles c'est nicholas ray ou
frédéric beigbeder
je connais voix se connait moisselles
celle de frédéric beigbeder
c'est ça que tu es assez sage ces
derniers temps on peut un peu le dire
celui qui écrivait meilleurs livres soit
bd ou nicolas rey sur ses gaffes luis et
acariâtre qui songe à laquelle est le
plus important est ce que c'est mieux de
se fâcher que nicholas ray avec
beigbeder s'est pas trop fait ce que tu
veux je crois que nicolas est en train
de monter en puissance et pas pareil
peut-être que nicolas plus de facilité
et du mal et et plus puis à ses épaules
et c'est celui qui tient le mieux
l'alcool dans les soirées c'est nicolas
et frédéric beigbeder il ya eu il ya eu
quelques soirées qu'est ce qu'on fait
sur cet effet comme soirée alcoolisée il
y avait la soirée champomy c'était très
bien mais ça c'était bien on a fait une
soirée tisane également oui frédéric
était torché en fait on l'a vu ne tient
pas du tout celui qui est le plus à
l'aise devant une caméra c'est nicolas
et frédéric beigbeder c'est certainement
pas moi je crois qu'on l'aura compris je
suis citoyen suicide toi t'as pas de
votre choix
je vois c'est ce soir c'est ce soir est
ce que est ce que je peux peut-être vous
rappelez faire un vote par par sms zone
amériques de silhouettes nicolas de plus
à l'aise pisa l'aide dans l'hyper chose
c'était frédéric celui qui finira grand
écrivain c'est beigbeder ou nicolas rey
se reconnaît mais y accueillait toujours
public sous tension
lui il se dit c'est horrible bas un
jeune écrivain assez talentueux se chier
dessus en direct
celui qui finira par une overdose dans
les toilettes du vip cfb génique des
pour une overdose de quoi on avait parlé
tout à l'heure de la tisane qu'est-ce
qui a vu comme il ya vu des overdoses
frédéric aime bien les bonbons c'est
vrai faut qu'il fasse attention il peut
grossir il est un peu court c'est lui
qui est moins insupportable qu'il en a
l'air c'est beigbeder ou nicolas nicolas
rey est encore plus gentil qu'il en a
l'air et l'a jamais l'état jamais l'air
insupportable c'est vrai gros melon
c'est quand j'étais petit j'ai arraché
les ailes des mouches
ouais tu me compare à une mouche j'ai
l'impression de faire [ __ ] bah non
dommage celui qui vous énerve le plus si
vous ne connaissiez pas assez nicolas et
frédéric beigbeder mais je ne les
connais tous les deux qui après 22
heures je pense que je les connais pas
vraiment en fait je pense que beigbeder
une bonne faculté être énervant le plus
superficiel des deux celle qu'elle
savait mois jean pla très peu de motifs
et ouvrir les veines tout et puis il ya
du matos on peut manger
celui qui est le plus opportuniste d2
c'est nicolas et frédéric beigbeder
ballon beigbeder on l'a vu dès qu'ils
aient l'occasion par une grande émission
de télé il l'a fait
d'ailleurs j'y avais participé et ça a
très bien marché donc je pense que les
deux sont les grosses écoute on m'a
donné l'occasion de répondre à celui qui
a la plus grosse [ __ ] s'est aguerri
meilleur passage vite sur la quatrième
de gaulle
s'il ya une [ __ ] de diable par contre on
a une grosse but de dida badi alors il
est temps que différentes y en a c'est
plus une berline et l'autre est plus un
coupé sport maintenant ce qu'il faut que
je rentre dans les détails
c'est ce dernier invité de la saison en
même temps tu payes pour les autres
pour nous il est 2h
longtemps